[Music]
actually is with us in New York City
hi actually how are you good how are you
there
better than I deserve what's up excited
a career in the job feel that I thought
I would love and why do like it it's not
paying enough and thinking of becoming a
nanny and that will help me get out of
my student loan debt it'll help my help
me and my mom got out of that completely
as well
your boss after then well see she lost
her job a couple years ago and took like
a $20,000 pay cut so when I'm back home
I started helping her out because I
started calling her because she wasn't
able to make the payments anymore for
some of the bills so I started helping
her out and you know when the fridge
broke is I eat the food in the fridge
and it still broke I eat the still
that's cooked on that fridge and she
used a credit card to pay for that so
it's the least I can do when you say
you're helping out how much are you
paying her one of our income so whenever
increase is completely going to staff
right now that's including I say about
twenty twenty-nine thousand of credit
card debt so how much does a new mic how
much I make thirty one thousand a year
and she's are your planner fifteen
thousand dollars a year to live there
yeah how old is this woman oh my mom's
almost 50 and I'm 22
okay so maybe she lives at 50 years old
in a place she can't afford because
they're 22 year old daughter is taking
care of her well the thing is we were
living well above our means and then
when she lost her job the bills stayed
of like the death rate the minimum
payments for the credit cards to say the
same like she wasn't able to afford that
I agree we literally owned the apartment
so all we pay is dirt cheap for New York
City so the living is not the issue it's
just the payments that kind of once you
gets caught up it's fine I don't need to
help her
but you're broke we are broke no we
aren't anything you're 22 she's 50 yeah
they're not married no I mean this is a
little whacked on how you guys are
approaching this so anyway
hang tight a minute and let's talk when
we come out of this break cuz I want to
get back to your career thing I got
sidetracked with your mother and I want
to make sure I talk to you about and
answer your question and help you okay
so hang with me I'll be right back this
is the Dave Ramsey show I'm talking with
Ashley in New York she's 22 she lives
with her mom who's 50 mom's got a great
deal on rent and gotten herself in
trouble so I actually been paying half
the bills around there and and she's
thinking about changing careers to a
nanny and that's about how far we got in
the discussion so actually how much debt
do you personally have and that's on
student loans hundred and student loans
are I'm sorry say that again not on
student loan okay is that all you've got
in debt yeah okay all right good deal
and what do you make now you said you
made 31 now right and what do you do now
I work at a non-profit doing what case
manager okay so you got a degree in
social work maybe basically just a bath
oh okay
all right cool and so your plan was to
come out of college and go into Social
Work which is what you're doing which is
what you're doing but 31000 in New York
City doesn't doesn't pay a lot of bills
right can't even afford a thousand
dollars worth of rent a month right very
difficult very difficult mm-hmm and it's
without a thousand dollar phoneme hardly
rent anything and yeah and so alright
and so you're thinking about nanny
and you would make how much nannying I
have about $20 $20 an hour for like 40
hours a week and is that the that's the
going rate okay so $800 a week then on
50 weeks that would put you more like a
$40,000 income yeah that sound about
right instead of a 31 so you make more
nannying than you would Social Work in
your area
my guess honestly is if you were in
Manhattan you'd make more than that oh
yeah definitely that's just like a baby
baby like entry level essentially thank
you you get a raise at least six months
basically but not for profit the reason
they're short and few and far between
yeah yeah okay all right so then the
next question is you're 22 when you're
32 or 42 what do you want to be doing
with your life career-wise I'm going to
be a school social workers well that's
the end goal but I want to pay off my
undergraduate student loan and hopefully
save up money to pay for my graduate
degree okay so to be a school social
worker you would need a masters mm-hmm
and then that would pay what that was
paying and she level at least 50/50 is
fifty to sixty thousand okay all right
and if you got an inexpensive master's
you don't spend a busy you don't spend
two hundred thousand dollars on your
masters then that would make sense okay
yeah okay and you could work your way
into that all right good okay to answer
your original question then yes I would
move towards nannying as a temporary
thing
not as a good long-term career choice
but maybe for the next four or five
years not only to get out of that but
then to save your money to create the
ability to pay cash for your master's
finish so that by the time you're 30 -
you're making 60 in the classroom
happening in a school as a social worker
so we want to work toward we want to
make take the steps to work towards the
long-term goal not just in quotes I need
to make more money okay not never hurts
to make more thank you I'm scared
like putting my dream on hold just
because of the money or not you're
working towards your dream yeah
because right now you can't do your
dream until you do the Masters and
you're too broken get out of that oh
yeah so this actually takes you towards
your dream that's why I'm participating
with you in it I agree with you all
right
I think it's a good idea now I want I
want to put one more thing in this okay
you are not responsible to take care of
your mother is responsible to take care
of her I know I know I know I know I
know I know
so here's what needs to happen there
sometime not this month but sometime in
the next two or three months the two of
you need to have a discussion that
sounds like this mom you're 50 I want to
participate and help you I can pay you
normal room employment if you're a nanny
would you live with someone else well if
you got live in that would solve all
this women mm-hmm
because here's the deal you would go
from $31,000 of which you only keep 15
your mother's taking the other and you
would go to 40 plus that 15 yeah if you
got a live-in and moved out from her
yeah it's kind of scary if when I said
that out loud though because you want to
take care of your mom I'm gonna try as
much just until she can afford the
minimum payments on her own yeah yeah
she and take out this debt because of
you also benefited me no not much I see
your opinion much no I mean really you
didn't buy the stove she buy the stove
because of you she didn't either
dishwasher because of you she did all
this because of her and then she wants
your help to clean it up I mean really
well she doesn't know why I
first I know some reason or some reason
in your family scrip you feel guilty if
you don't do this and on the other side
I've got a 26 year old son and if I
thought he had to take care of me it
would more to find me yeah that's the
normally the parent are taking care of
the kid not the other way around
especially at this age at this age so
you need to get if you stay in that
house you need to convert your deal to
normal room and board if you were to
move in with someone else and you paid
normal room and board in that area what
would you pay it would not be $15,000 a
year okay and you need to just say this
is my room and board and I can pay this
and then mom I'll help you with your
finances but this idea that somehow you
have combined your finances and you guys
are like living like some kind of weird
married couple or something I mean it's
just strange kid it's not working it's a
weird some weird stuff going on so y'all
y'all need to separate your finances you
need to pay room and board if you're
going to stay there but I think the best
thing for you and for your mom by the
way would be for you to move out and get
a live-in nanny gig hey thanks for
calling in I hope I helped hope I
disturbed you a little bit because
that's part of what my job is in a
loving way